look okay it's not my fault I bet
nothing's ever your fault is it darling
you have thrown away your life working
in some silly Christmas shop this is my
little helper I have nicknamed her lazy
that alphago she appears never to walk
so there's really just kidding what
Jesus what's your comfort well what are
you looking at
oh I think you're just peed in your eye
yeah I think it's good luck you know
what is impudent my bet
I'm busy you're weird good bye you've
missed five doctor's appointments
mum is scared so tell me about the sleep
never exercised at all alcohol oh she's
like the pirate no okay fine thank you
doctor thank you so much be fun let's go
ma'am you again what do you mean again
did you follow me here are elves always
so cynical
yes relentlessly these are dark times
I'm Tom Kate
every bit where you murder me so what is
it that you do I sing oh it's amazing
anyway boring boring boring I'm gonna
bored where are you going when that well
you're not homeless
no I volunteer why don't you just get
saved I do - no 4head you were great at
your job when you started right now it's
like you don't care anymore oh yeah hi
hi Kyle
I'm a mess I was really sick and I
nearly died I don't tell people cuz they
get weird but I don't think you'll get
weird
no I'm just scared all the time but they
just expect me to be normal
okay always life there's no such thing
as normal it's just being a human being
is hard maybe you should do something
nice for someone deck the halls with
boughs of holly fella nananana lalala
tis the season to be jolly oh boy
I've been volunteering the shelter
seriously this sounds like a healthy
choice what's wrong with you I've been
trying to find you you keep disappearing
then when I do I think you accidentally
I might add it wasn't accidental
[Applause]
why me it's always gonna be here okay
like I'm gonna make mistakes and that's
okay you're made of everything you do
[Music]
[Applause]